okay well we back again
we in our session
on model selection
we've seen best subset regression
forward stepwise regression and we've
seen how to use a validation set to do
model selection
as well as using the the built-in cp um
statistic that's that's recorded by reg
subsets
now we're going to use cross validation
which is one of our preferred methods
for doing a model selection and we'll
use uh 10-fold cross-validation
and once again we're using our our
markdown
session
um so we're gonna we can record text and
and the r commands at the same time and
at the end of it all we'll be able to
produce a nice document showing what
we've we've done
so
let's look at the the script and and see
how we do this
okay so
there's our our markdown code this is a
second level heading
so model selection by cross validation
and as i said we're going to use tenfold
cross validation
and it's really easy and you know
people you can write functions for doing
this but it's so easy to do that it's
actually good just to know how to do it
on the fly
so we'll set a random number c just like
we did before we'll use a different one
this time so we'll set the seed to be
11.
and so
here we're going to sample from the
numbers 1 to 10.
each observation is going to be assigned
a fold number and they're 10 folds
so
we're going to sample from the numbers 1
to 10 so we create a vector 1 to 10 of
length the number of rows of hitters
okay
so that'll try and make an equal number
of ones equal number of twos up to equal
number of tens
and and then we're going to random
basically shuffle that and that's what
the sample command does here
okay so we do that and then if we look
at it
there's our random assignment of folds
to each of the observations in hitters
and if we tabulate that these are just
numbers between 1 and 10.
you'll see it's pretty balanced
it couldn't be exactly balanced with a
sample size of 263
but as close as can be so there's either
26 or 27 in in each false
in each fold
okay so we make now a matrix for our
errors and it's going to have
10 rows and 19 columns because they're
19 variables they're going to be 19
subsets
and 10 rows for each of the 10 folds
and so now we're going to go through a
double loop
and so we go for k equals 1 in 10
and now we fit a reg subsets model
with salary as a response
and the training data is going to be all
the observations whose fold id is not
equal to k
for the this kth fold
we're going to train on all the
observations but those in the kth fold
okay
so
having done that we only need to do that
once and now we're going to go and look
at each of the subsets in that trained
model so now we go through our loop for
i equals 1 to 19
and now we can use our predict method
that we just made
and when i say predict method i mean it
because we wrote our predict function in
a way that the generic predict
understands
and so
we just call predict
and the first argument is is best.fit
which is a reg subsets object and so
the generic function predict knows to
find the method which was called predict
subsets
and
now we're going to make predictions
at those observations whose folds fold
id is equal to k
right so those were the guys that were
left out
and we doing it for each subset size
i
which is given to our predict function
by id
okay so we make our predictions
and then we compute the mean squared
error of the predictions and assign that
into the kth row of our cv errors
and we do that for for all the
i and for all k and that's done already
well actually it's not
now it's done
so that was pretty quick that was fit in
19 no it was fit in 10 models so it's
not so bad but making predictions for 19
different sub-models of each
um we now process our output matrix so
first of all
we use the apply function to the columns
so we take the column means
right because there were 10 rows
and each row was the
mean squared error for a particular fold
but we want to average those so we
average down the columns and then we use
square root to get the root mean squared
error
and now we can make a plot of that
and so there's our 10-fold
cross-validation
curve
it's not quite as jumpy as the
validation curve because this is
averaged over the full training set the
errors are computed over the full
training set
but of course in done fold by fold but
then averaged so it's a little bit
smoother and this seems to favor models
of size 11 or 12.